j'ai une petite surprise pour toi tu es
coach of the world skies
ouais et tu sais qu'ici on aime recevoir
des nouveaux talents dans tpm p alors on
t'a prévu le même siège de demander de
bien vouloir te mettre dans ce siège
c'est parti c'est pour amel bent ses
oppresseurs
je vais faire rentrer des gens qui vont
chanter tu ne les verras pas et tu vas
me dire tu vas te retourner ou pas tu
veux te retourner c'est inclus bien
beaucoup hein alors abel est ce que tu
m'entends salle houdart on est en duplex
ar oui oui oui je vous entends hamel
hamel je sais que tu as quelques
kilomètres à mais là je vais faire
entrer des gens qui vont chanter n'a car
comme dans the voice tu vas décidé de te
retourner ou pas d'accord d'accord ma
chérie voici le premier chanteur
c'est parti
[Musique]
une histoire qu'on peut surprendre là
c'est foutu
oui et j'ai vu dans son regard
un train
faire semblant
des droits
à retiens pas tes
[Musique]
et ton chat
[Applaudissements]
tiendra-t-il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toi que je sais on se rappelle
d'ailleurs à la remercier danse dans son
premier album il était il était
directeur de la maison du peuple de guy
môquet à la courneuve dans laquelle elle
occupait il s'occupait des jeunes du
quartier et s'occuper d'un mail et
jennifer qui est ça qui était sa
meilleure amie à l'époque
hamel hamel tennis sur une folle ou pas
je suis choqué pas vraiment et choqué tu
t'en tardez pas du tout parce que bruno
avec toi on dit que c'est son deuxième
papa vous prennez s'occuper de moi je
peux banderas il m'a empêché traîner
dans les rues quoi tu vois je nous vois
pas tous les petits du quartier et nous
on est venu nous trouver des activités
il nous a poussés à nous exprimer à 10
ans et sa mère
tu perds tu l'assumés tout le temps
d'autant tout le temps tout en était fan
d'apple
je suis toujours fan de même et jennifer
alors jennifer s est une amie d'enfance
vous avez rencontré lorsque vous aviez
14 ans amène à la vie de 10 ans et vous
avez fondé même un groupe qui s'appelle
et sweat lady's jamais vous avez acheté
d'argent pour m'acheter une mèche pony
gens qui connaissent attendais pas du
tout avoir
tu ne fais pas maintenant ça fait
combien de temps que tu l'as pas vu on
saison s'est recroisé nous serrons la
balle et les forêts maintenant invitée
sur l'émission ça fait 10 ans se fait
piller a reconnu sa voix au pas du tout
j'imagine toujours connu ça va mais j'ai
reconnu a aimé la voir faire reconnu une
bête de voix par alors il paraît que
vous chantiez toutes les doses the boy
is my den brande et monica la vie tout
cela va nous faire un petit truc un vrai
je me rappelle même plus de la chanson
mais pas jennifer tu peux nous ferons
pas j'en dis que c'est vrai qu'on a
m
[Applaudissements]
ma
une voix exceptionnelle jennifer merci
d'abord je vous aime
elle est franchement hâte à une voix
exceptionnelle
si tu voulais faire a mis un petit
plaisir voilà je voulais la revoir on
n'a pas l'occasion va vous ouvrir des
apéritifs x